hello everyone and welcome to a
completely new month in 2020
uh hopefully no no new nasty discoveries
will be made this year
and we are continuing the good stuff
it's our uh
uh 1858 odds match between reverend john
owen and paul charles murphy and this is
the last game we'll be showing from
their match
as it is quite an interesting one but
there there are more matches to be
uh shown from uh the morphe saga uh so
this one is a really awesome game and it
features two very nice positive video
moments so i do hope you enjoyed it uh
you will enjoy it
uh so uh oven again opens with e4 and
morphe replies with the d6 we're not
going to be naming any openings as
morphe is playing without his
f pawn so d4 by one end knight to f6 and
here already uh the fun starts as owen
taunts morphy with bishop the c4 he
wants morphy to capture on e4
which would unleash a very unpleasant
attack for white and morphy has to
decide whether he wants to keep
developing or
grab the e4 pawn and if morphe would go
for the e4 pawn
then we just go into the very nice uh
queen h5 check
g6 and now queen to d5 going for the
knight end for
uh queen to f7 uh so best for black
would be just a retreat with the knight
knight f6
attack the queen and force this queen f7
check king d7
bishop to e6 checking c6 d5 check and
now after the king moves
we will get this position where uh black
king wouldn't be in the
in the greatest of squares but you know
morphy's seen
worse positions against uh owen in this
odds match so
maybe it could be possible it would be
possible to play this
uh but morphy doesn't go for his morphe
just continues developing he doesn't go
for the e4 pawn
knight to c6 and now knight to c3 owen
also continues with development with e6
by morphy
and knights to f3 and morphy strikes in
the center with the d5 like he would if
he was playing a normal game
we have bishop to d3 and now bishop to
b4 putting pressure on the knight which
means
putting pressure on the e4 pawn as you
are pinning one of the defenders
so bishop to g5 uh probably
just capturing here or something like e5
is also playable but bishop to g5
is uh well maybe not all that impressive
because it forces
whites to make decisions morphy just
plays h6
and now uh he he asks what do you what
do you want to do here do you want to
capture on d5 do you want to play
bishop captures on f6 but owen again
goes for the
uh you know in the spirit of barnes goes
for e5 he really wants to give this
bishop the g6 check
and it's not a position without any
poison as you'll see
morphy captures on g5 with bishop to g6
with
check king to f8 and now knight captures
and g5 and now it's not really
an easy decision for black so there's
only one move that really gives us a
morphe the advantage and now
feel free to pause the video here you're
getting attacked you know barnes style
by owen
uh feel free to pause the video and find
the best move for black well i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on cracking
not at all an easy position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
rook the h6 is the move for black here
if you try anything weird like
moving the knight for example knight e4
then queen f3 just
gets the job done for white if you move
the king you're getting queen f7 so
you'd have to move the knight back and
then knight f7 comes attacking the queen
the rook
uh the knight will also fall uh black
just uh falls apart here so here morphe
does play rook to h6
and it is a it is a problematic move for
white because now it's white who needs
to make a decision
now the whole point of rook to h6 is
that after knight f7 which attacks
both queen and the rook queen e8 is
really awesome
uh now knight captures on h6 you play
queen captures on g6 and you attack the
knight there's no
a good square for the knight so after
pawn captures you're going to play
queen captures on h6 after f captures on
g7 would check you're going to recapture
and after white attempts to check your
king uh you will move the king and you
will have this position
uh where it's going to be a really
really good position for black
your king is a bit oddly placed but you
do have a knight and a bishop for uh for
white's uh
rook and the white still has to decide
what to do uh if you
even if you cast a queen side to defend
the pawn even ideas like knight captures
are possible fouled by pushing of of the
pawns
so black is definitely better here and
this is what morphe had in mind when he
played rook to h6
i i presume uh so bishop back to d3 by
owen
and now not capturing the pawn right
away first morphe improves the position
still moving the knight just results in
now queen to f3 check you don't you do
not want to allow this
so king to g8 now morphe is ready to
move the knight but now of course owen
captures it so pawn captures we have
queen captures on f6
uh and now as the knight is again
threatened on g5
knight back to f3 and now it seems like
everything is perfectly fine
white captured some pawns went back and
now uh
still gets to enjoy uh his uh his extra
pawn but not really
because here morphe goes for e5 and now
there's already a threat of uh well
he captures on d4 just attacking the
knight but more
even just e4 with a double attack on the
bishop and the knight
so here the characters we have knight
captures and again owen in a very
unpleasant position
uh best for owen here would be just to
capture the knight on e5 and you would
have to go into this queen captures an
e5 check
uh queen e2 isn't good because of your
bishop captures on c3 with chuck
followed by captures captures so king f1
would have to be played and now rook
captures here uh
rook characters queen captures and now
uh well
white is in uh is in a pretty pretty bad
position but he actually gets the
hang on with queen to f3 you actually
don't care about queen to h1 check
but uh things like this you know seeing
in seeing things like this in 1858
would would require a lot of time over
the board and a lot of concentration
which i don't think
uh anyone in those days really really
committed to unless it was like a really
really
important game the point is that after
queen to h1 check you can just move the
king and if queen captures here you get
queen captures on d5
and now uh you're just you're just doing
very well
uh if queen if king to h8 then queen d8
will just deliver checkmate as the
bishop covers the h7 square of course
after bishop blocks and captures and if
king f8 and bishop g6 just poses a lot
of problems for black and even though
black
gets to avoid being checkmated he will
have to give up
a lot of material to avoid it for
example to avoid checkmate you need to
play some like bishop g for check
f3 and now rook checks uh white will
give up the bishop
but now for example you can just check
the king and now pick up the bishop for
example king
f7 you're gonna capture on b4 and you're
just gonna have a better position and
you're even up a pawn
uh so that's that's what would happen so
point being after queen to f3
uh black doesn't uh go for this check
followed by captures black can just
defend his spawn
and now the game can continue uh with
white really you know grasping for
straws here you'd have to go
bishop to f5 uh to again go for this
check if black attempts something like
this so after bishop to f7 you finally
go queen h3
force a queen trade and then you
continue playing the sand game
which is well would best play white will
probably be able to draw this
however that's a lot to expect uh
for someone from uh you know playing
this game in 1858 so here instead of
capturing an e5
owen just castled but now there is a
problem uh feel free to pause the video
and win this game for white
uh the the fastest way possible uh well
i'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not
capturing the knight because even though
this gives you a favorable position it
doesn't give you any uh you know real
winning advantage you you will be better
here but nothing
nothing special uh however for those of
you who found queen to f4
this is now a really really big threat
because now you're
you're just threatening to capture the
knight with check and after
queen or pawn recaptures you're going to
play queen captures on h2 with checkmate
because now removing the defender of
checkmate comes
with check so you don't really have any
good options here
if g3 then just the knight hangs with
check not not
much can be done about that and if
another thing is played well it's not
much better here your options are like
h3 h4 something like that uh or maybe
even rook to e1 making room for the king
but none of it actually works
rook the e1 is the most resilient option
however owen went for
pawn to h4 if pawn to h3 it's not much
better here morphic can just give up the
rook and it still
uh ends in checkmate for example knight
captures on f3 would
check as the uh f3 knight is no longer
defended
and after king moves you're going to
play bishop captures on h3 with
check remove the uh the king and now
queen h4 check king g2
queen g4 check king's gonna move and now
queen to h3 checkmate
so this is what happens if you go for uh
for h3 so owen went for h4
but now morphy just uh gets the job done
and now he just plays knight
captures on f3 with check queen captures
and queen captures on h4 now threatening
both queen to h2 or queen to h1
checkmate so
g3 doesn't really give you anything even
though you you can guard the h1 square
you cannot guard the h2 square
so here owen played queen captures on d5
with czech bill morphy just defended
with bishop to e6
and it was in this position on move 18
that uh
reverend john owen resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
you're either getting checkmated or if
you're
if you want to defend against checkmate
to make an escape route for your king
then you give up the queen and of course
there's nothing more to be done here
which owen knew and of course here he
resigned the game and even though morphe
lost that famous game where owen played
the the owens defense
uh you know probably gave birth to owens
defense in that game
uh morphy then challenged him to a match
and in the seven games they played
morphy won five games uh without the
f-pawn and two of the games were drawn
so morphy did not lose a single game in
this match
uh so that's uh that's all there is to
the match with owen uh do i do hope you
guys enjoyed that and now morphe is
still waiting to face
staunton howard stanton that's why he he
came all the way to
uh to london and uh here uh the thing is
after
after this match uh staunton postponed
his match against morphy one more time
uh as uh i'm gonna read you a very very
short part from david lawson's book
about paul morphy it goes yet it was
staunton with whom morphe most desire to
play however
very soon after their first meeting
staunton asked that their match be
postponed
until after the birmingham meeting in
august we already mentioned that during
the saga
morphe agreed to this second
postponement and staunton affirmed the
agreement in the illustrated london news
so on the 10th of july 1858 it said in
the
uh illustrated london news mr morphy has
preferred
to play mr staunton a match of 21 games
for a stake of 500 pounds aside
and the latter has accepted the
challenge conditionally that the terms
of play are such
that he can agree to without infraction
of his present literary engagements uh
basically meaning that
uh morphy needs to present such a
challenge that uh
staunton can uh you know accept the
challenge without it being uh
too much of a problem for him as he's a
very busy guy obviously
as there appears every disposition on
the part of his opponent
to meet his wishes in this respect the
match will probably take place in london
shortly after the birmingham chess
meeting uh and uh
well that's that's all we know for now
during this saga and while morphe is
waiting for his
match with staunton uh he will now again
uh fa
uh face against his old friend
laurenthal
uh we already uh showed a few games uh
from their match uh in uh the 1850
uh where loganfeld played the morphe
when he when he was still uh not even a
13 year old boy and now
uh of course elemental needs to clear
his name is now he again gets his chance
to face off against morphy
and he challenges morphy to another
match and this is the match that we are
going to cover next uh in the paul
morphy saga
uh so yeah uh that's uh the game ended
the match against reverend john owen i
do hope you enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank erica tencio
harris uh frank combs nick blackwell uh
west allendale and goku g for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day